[Musique]
périco légasse bonsoir voila nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui sur une chaîne
youtube une chaîne internet en direct
qui s'appelle think ur view on voudrait
avoir votre avis sur la malbouffe sur ce
qui se passe au niveau de notre
alimentation
les nouvelles tendances comme le
véganisme et des choses comme ça on
commence par quoi
ce que vous voulez
alors on va poser une question très
technique est ce que la mondialisation
est en train de nous empoisonner
alors la
mondialisation en soi non elle a
toujours existé dans l'histoire des
hommes à différentes échelles à
différentes périodes c'est la
globalisation
qui nous tue qui nous emprisonne dans la
mesure où la globalisation fait en sorte
de mettre les systèmes de production au
service de la finance
aujourd'hui c'est flagrant moi j'ai une
définition très simple sur la malbouffe
qui est vraiment le l'alimentation le
secteur qui me touche on est en train de
financiarisé l'alimentation c'est à dire
que tu as besoin vital est naturel de
l'humanité qui est de se nourrir le
système fait en sorte une partie du
système le système néolibéral
j'allais dire mercantile fait ressort de
financiarisé ce besoin est à dire qu ont
contraint les masses à consommer d'une
certaine façon de façon à ce que cette
forme de consommation puisse engendrer
le maximum de profits faciles pour le
système économique je vais me faire
l'avocat du diable est ce que ce système
là nous donne pas en fait accès à plus
de nourriture ne démocratise pas la
nourriture auprès des gens avec un
faible pouvoir d'achat c'était le but la
grande distribution quelque part quand
elle l'est dans les années 50 en
bretagne c'était une forme de socialisme
c'est comment on va faire en sorte que
des gens qui n'ont pas les moyens
puissent accéder à des produits qui en
général sont prohibitifs pour eux et on
va regrouper les achats pour faire
baisser les prix parce qu'on regroupe
les achats de façon à ce que le
consommateur
pas très argentés les classes plutôt
défavorisés puissent excéder un certain
type de produits ça marche tellement
bien que finalement on rentre dans un
engrenage où on va commencer à
surproduire pour surconsommer lorsque
les marges de la grande distribution
sont assez faibles elle ne peut marcher
de façon vraiment lucrative que sur la
quantité que sur la masse donc on rend
dans la consommation de masse à laquelle
va s'adapter tout le système de
production notamment l'agriculture c'est
à dire qu'on va demander à l'agriculture
là où on produisait 10 tonnes sur 100
hectares on va lui demander de produire
100 tonnes sur 10 hectares et on va
industrialisés nos campagnes pour
baisser les coûts de production de façon
à ce que évidemment on dit au
consommateur vont baisser les prix non
on baisse pas les prix en augmente vos
marges et ce système économique c'est
qu'à un moment donné on attaque les
ressources de la planète on attaque le
système on attaque l'environnement on
attaque notre santé et la surproduction
financiarisé de notre consommation
alimentaire provoque aujourd'hui
dépollution des maladies
et surtout la ruine le cette agriculture
qui étaient là pour nous donner ce dont
nous avions besoin je joue pour une
parenthèse c'est une question qui était
réclamé par la communauté vous étiez sur
lcp récemment vous avez balancé un truc
sont sources concernant mac do et les
statines
quelle était votre source alors j'étais
sur
l'émission que j'anime qui s'appelle
manger c'est voter
manger c'est voter j'aborde ces
questions là et effectivement
les laboratoires fiser aux états unis
ont proposé un mcdo il ya quelques
années j'ai dit la source la source
était un document que j'avais lu du
monsieur pierre weill qui ouvrage
s'appelle manger on s'occupe du reste
édité chez plon et ce chercheur français
qui est aussi leur quelqu'un qui est
très engagée dans le combat alimentaire
cité cette information qui pour
l'instant n'a pas été démenti que les
laboratoires fiser avait proposé à mcdo
de placer à la sortie des restos des
distributeurs de statines et un méchant
statines serré molécules qui combat le
cholestérol et alors au départ les deux
les deux sociétés avaient trouvé ça très
bien et un responsable de mcdo quelques
questions sur la communication avait dit
mais si on met des statines qui est un
médicament à la sortie des mcdo cela
veut dire que nous vendrons quelque part
de la maladie puisqu'on en donne le
médicament pour la évidemment
l'opération ne s'était pas fait mais on
voit à quel moment le système s'emballe
et andy bell coûté oui on pose un
problème mais on a la solution donc oui
quand il égrène en terme d'image et et
c'est vraiment sûr de la source et béton
c'est trianguler sait car il n'y a pas
de problème je sais pas j'ai page et je
connais ma source j'ai pas vérifié que
le professeur en question
avait écrit n'importe quoi ça n'a pas
été démenti je pense que c'est
suffisamment lourd et significatif pour
que si ça avait été en plus je les écris
moi déjà sur d'autres sur d'autres
médias je pense que si c'était pas vrai
les intéressés auraient réagi huo
réactif et la formation
on va passer une autre question
c'est démocratisation de l'alimentation
qu'est ce qui se passe si on inverse ou
système là si on dit voilà les pauvres
non
n'auront pas accès à tous qu'est ce
qu'on fait on leur propose un système
alternatif on leur propose quoi parce
qu'il faut bien que les gens mangent
aussi alors d'abord c'est pas une
démocratisation
c'est une banalisation
pour une consommation de masse et en
faire baisser les prix aujourd'hui on le
sait c'est faire baisser la qualité
était au rendez vous allez payer moins
cher mais on n'a pas le courage de m
comme sur un paquet de tabac fumé rend
malade ou fumer tue malbouffe et rend
malade et malbouffe et tu la malle vous
vient de quoi de l'effondrement de la
qualité consécutif à l'effondrement des
prix donc la solution elle est simple
elle n'est pas générale il ya des cas
des figures sociologique ou géographique
où on peut pas toujours appliquée et moi
ce que je dis aujourd'hui dans le
système occidental industrialisés
l'hémisphère nord nous consommons trop
on mange trop en quantité et surtout on
mange trop de mauvaise alimentation je
prends l'exemple de la viande moi ce que
je propose et c'est simple puisque nous
mangeons trop nous le savons les
nutritionnistes nous le disent trop de
graisse trop de protéines trop de trop
déçu trop de suzanne est ce qu'on peut
réduire cette quantité
d'aliments est ce qu'on peut manger
moins quantitativement ça va forcément
engendrer une économie et avec ses
économies on va améliorer la qualité ce
qu'on achète je prends l'exemple de que
je cite dans mon bouquin à table
citoyens pour heymans et nous émanciper
de la malbouffe et sauvé nos paysans
s'échapper l'équation de 18 6 10 8 6 3 g
puis dj 6-3 j'aurais pu être 21 3 27
c'est à dire sur un budget de 18 euros
quel que soit mon milieu social c'est
par semaine c'est par jour c'est par
mois les 8 euros au lieu d'acheter six
fois un morceau de viande à 3 euros
dégueulasse provenant d'un élevage qui
respectent pas l'animal qui polluent qui
nourrit pas son éleveur ou six fois un
fromage à 3 euros industriel dégueulasse
fait avec du lait de navès provenance
j'inverse je fais trois fois un morceau
de viande à 6 euros qui provient d'un
élevage élevé pas et paysans d'une
vaches nourries à l'herbe ça je fais
trois fois un fromage fermier à 6 euros
et pas 3 euros on dit mais le reste du
temps du coup oui mais 6-3 3-6 qu'est-ce
qu'on fait les faux je mange pas et ben
il ya aujourd'hui suffisamment de choix
alimentaires dans la grande distribution
et dans le commerce pour qu'on puisse
réduire notre consommation à trois
morceaux à 6 euros de viande par semaine
par mois comme on veut et avec cet
argent cette économie a acheté une
qualité meilleure et le reste du temps
eh bien je fais des légumes je fais des
pâtes il ya une une profusion de
produits alimentaires dans la diversité
de bonne qualité et pas chère du tout y
compris dans le grand disciple rue et
surtout nos agents distribution la
grande distribution pour moi aujourd'hui
c'est le principal fléau puisque c'est
elle qui est un peu plus de façon
structurelle à travers le monde
l'effondrement des prix soit disant pour
préserver le pouvoir d'achat du
consommateur
cet effondrement des prix aujourd'hui il
est arrivé à un tel stade faut prendre
les choses correctement au début faire
baisser le prix d'un trip est un petit
peu cher c'est cohérent quand on
continue à dire aux producteurs aux
céréaliers au producteur de légumes à
l'éleveur fois encore baisser les prix
et même à l'industriel l'agro-industrie
à qui on dit les grands groupes à qui on
dit vous allez baisser les prix quand on
dit même à nestlé qui est premier on dit
tu vas bct plie parce que j'ai tapé et
bien
l'agroalimentaire l'industrie elle est
obligée en baissant ses plus de déchets
la qualité a en effet factuel on peut
pas réduire les marches sans réduire la
qualité du produit utilisé donc la
grande distribution dans le low cost et
c'est pas moi qui le dit ça monsieur qui
s'appelle georges place a été pdg de
carrefour il a accordé en 2015 une
interview au figaro il a dit le low cost
c'est la fin du monde pourquoi parce que
l'effondrement des prix c'est
l'appauvrissement pour tout le monde on
abaisse la qualité on a baissé les
salaires on abaisse les rendements et
c'est une logique destructrice qui mène
l'humanité à sa perte voilà donc les
choses ont un coût la qualité
d'environnement elle a un coût la
qualité de l'énergie elle a un coût la
qualité des vêtements et un coup à plus
forte raison la qualité de
l'alimentation et d'un coup il ya un
seuil au dessus duquel si vous descendez
d'accord vous allez payer moins cher
mais cette économie sa valeur négative
elle a un impact environnemental de
santé et de rétribution du producteur
qui est catastrophique et moi j'annonce
tout simplement si on continue sur cette
logique néolibérale de l'effondrement
des prix mais sans la qualité pour
assurer les marges de ceux qui
distribuent et bien la fin du monde ne
viendra pas de glaciation où la météo
deviendra l'espace et d'une implosion de
cette planète parce que ce système de
consommation il impose qu'on continue à
pomper les ressources de la terre on
pompe la planète on tient compte de rien
on prend parce que pour faire moins cher
on pond et aujourd'hui on sait en deux
18 on a passé le seuil de rentabilité
c'est à dire que tout ce qu'on consomme
aujourd'hui c'est au détriment des
ressources des générations qui voit on
est en train de taper dans le conte dans
la réserve de nos enfants et ça c'est le
système de consommation néolibérale
rendu à l'échelle de masse dans le pas
cher il faut inverser système ya que des
solutions le plus grand mensonge
politique aujourd'hui c'est de dire bien
mangé ça coûte cher mal manger ça coûte
très cher qu'est ce que vous pensez de
la décroissance
la décroissance j'ai si souvent cet
exemple que cite également une personne
que je connais mais que sap et natacha
polony quand le commandant du titanic
qui est à bord de son vaisseau il est
dans la modernité il est dans le progrès
il doit battre un record il doit relier
l'europe à new york machine avant tout
il est dans la croissance d'une
croissance qui est légitime on lui dit
attention il ya des icebergs il faudrait
peut-être réduire la vitesse et quand
ils voient l'iceberg et qui dit machine
arrière toute
c'est le contraire des consignes qu'il
avait reçue de son armateur c'est le
contraire de la vocation de ce bateau de
ce transatlantiques il veut aller vite
et bien quand il dit machine arrière
toute il fait de la décroissance mais
c'est une décroissance qui est vitale et
s'il avait fait sa décroissance attend
un petit peu avant il aurait peut-être
pas eu de 1800 morts que bord du titanic
qu'ils auraient pu éviter l'iceberg donc
quand on va trop vite comment le sketch
de fernand raynaud velluire devant moi 1
2 op il était temps à gauche toute ou à
droite tout je m'en fous quand on va
vers un obstacle qui va vous tuer s'il
faut freiner s'il faut faire marche
arrière s'il faut des vielles s'il faut
faire une pause et que cette pause
s'appelle la décroissance est bien me
pose pas de problème au contraire je
pense qu'elle est salutaire décroissance
ou à croissance on va trop vite on roule
à 130 sur une route qui devrait être
empruntée à 110 on roule à 110 sur un
chemin qui devrait à 60 un moment donné
des limitations de vitesse il ya des
limitations de consommation il ya des
limitations de folie il ya des
limitations de violence et bien les a
baissé parce qu'elle nous détruise pas
ce que nous ferons du mal si c'est ça la
décroissance alors vite passant la
décroissance
vous connaissez un peu la perception des
politiques concernant la décroissance
oui ils sont pas y sont ils sont pas
trop dans ce phénomène là parce que si
on contracte 1,6 les politiques en
général saute c'est normal si on
continue si on continue à demander à
donner ou à faciliter l'accès à de la
bouffe pas très cher c'est pour éviter
que la plèbe f1 toutes les révolutions
continent ont commencé parce qu'ils
appelaient mme chan si le politique se
met dans une idée d'accès des ratios
nist pour trouver une solution à tous
ces problèmes il est dans le déni pour
vous il est simplement ils essayent de
quand même sauver le système à sa façon
la classe politique elle est tenue mais
un dogme
incontournable incontestable quel
progrès le prêt obligatoire qui est la
vocation l'humanité
paradoxalement c'est plutôt une idée de
gauche le progrès puisque la droite on
est toujours céder conservateurs ces
voix là c'est des rétrogrades avec cet
élément nouveau qui est l'écologie
l'écologie c'est une préservation de
l'environnement c'est une conservation
d'un monde qui nous fait du bien on peut
donc dire que l'écologie elle est contre
le progrès donc elle est culturellement
de droite aujourd'hui elle est plutôt
porté par type par les partis de gauche
il ya une fois contradiction le progrès
n'est pas forcément
salutaire il n'est pas forcément
bénéfiques la classe politique elle est
tenue par se nomme le progrès non le
progrès de quoi est ce qu une
technologie qui est assassiné est ce que
un système militaire qui va tuer plus de
gens plus vite est ce qu'un système de
transport d'avion de voitures qui vont à
180 c le progrès bon c'était le béaba ce
que je dis le progrès n'est pas
forcément salutaire il ya aujourd'hui la
nécessité autour de cette terre qu à une
dimension précise est la tante surface
de terre tente surface de mer et une
écologie un écosystème et il ya une
ligne à une biodiversité pour la
préserver il faut faire un petit peu
moins de progrès et le progrès justement
c'est de faire marche arrière quelques
fois pour sauver ce qui reste alors oui
il faut réduire la consommation des
marges c'est-à-dire qu'il faut éduquer
les masses
à commencer par une éducation au niveau
scolaire en disant on consomme mal moi
je suis touché par la consommation
alimentaire mais c'est vrai pour tous
nous consommons au niveau de l'énergie
au niveau du vêtement au niveau de
déplacements automobiles au niveau des
transports on y voit locaux sont
normales nous consommons de façon
inutile aux abymes notre environnement
nous savions la planète
provoquant des pollutions qui font du
mal à la santé humaine et tout ça
pourquoi pour enrichir des systèmes qui
ont besoin eux deux sur produire pour
surconsommer pour s'enrichir voilà c'est
un système de consommation c'est une
croissance folle parce que la croissance
peut devenir folle c'est une croissance
folle qui obligeait système néolibéral
financier a su reproduire pour
surconsommer on sait aujourd'hui pour
des raisons objectives et scientifique
la preuve il fondait comme 21 que ce
système même la planète à sa perte donc
quelle est la solution
consommons moins une façon générale donc
des
défaisant une décroissance de
consommation pour en améliorer la
qualité vous à votre vie vous fait quoi
- en tant que journaliste j'ai c'est
d'informer mes lecteurs les
téléspectateurs les auditeurs les gens
qui m'écoutent aujourd'hui leur
demanderai de se réapproprier leur
système alimentaire je leur demande de
redevenir des citoyens consommateurs
responsables de faire attention à ce
qu'ils mettent dans leur assiette vous
faites quoi vous moi j'ai journaliste
doubler tous les jours fait quoi dans
votre vie à vous ça ce que je fais tout
le temps je passe ma vie à aller voir ce
qu'il ya sur le marché me renseigner
alerter je vais interpeller les citoyens
consommateurs quand je peux tels que je
fais là c'est le but des médias de leur
demander de prendre conscience qu'il
faut changer les choses je vais surtout
soutenir ma principale activité en
tanzanie je vais soutenir les gens qui
se battent je vais soucier des
producteurs je soutiens les paysans je
vais soutenir des artisans des gens qui
se donnent du mal pour qu'on ait une
consommation à visage humain
respectueuse de l'environnement de notre
santé il ya beaucoup de gens il ya des
millions de gens qui se battent il faut
qu'ils soient entendus il faut surtout
qu'ils aient de quoi vivre parce que le
paysan qui nous donne de la bonne bouffe
aujourd'hui il est plus 30 en crever il
finit souvent au bout d'une corde donc
pour empêcher que ce massacre prennent
des proportions dramatiques et surtout
ce sera irréversible
il reste peu de paysans en france il
faut rétablir une paysannerie qui nous
nourrissent et qui apporte au marché des
produits qui soient respectueux de
l'environnement qui nous fasse du bien
quand on les consomme vous parlez d'un
citoyen engagé qu'est ce que vous pensez
de l214
ils ont fait un travail formidable
l214
sur lequel j'ai des divergences de fond
lesquels terrible les kills je suis un
homme nivore je continuerai toujours à
manger de la viande même si ces
massacres le terrain et grâce à eux je
réponds à votre question grâce à eux je
me suis rendu compte que je manger trop
de viande trop de mauvaise viande et les
images qui nous ont permis de diffuser
qu'on a vus nous ont appris que dans des
abattoirs de la république française
vont penser que toutes les normes et des
garanties tuer un animal c'est toujours
un acte de violence mais on sait
aujourd'hui que les systèmes d'
étourdissements d'abattage qui sont
respectueuses normalement de la
souffrance animale j'ai vu tout ça a été
violée que partout en france dans les
endroits qu'on soupçonnait pas il y
avait des véritables actes de massacrer
les actes de barbarie donc merci l214
d'avoir dénoncé ce système qui est en
fait quoi la réponse a toujours même
chose il faut faire baisser les prix
pour les produits sont moins chers et
bien y compris au moment où on abat
l'animal faut le faire à toute vitesse
de façon monstrueuse de façon à ce que
tout le monde puisse faire du profit
voilà si on consomme moins on n'a pas
besoin de se repasser des brebis des
cochons ou des vaches à une telle
vitesse à une telle cadence dans des
abattoirs où il soit bête où ils sont
tués de façon absolument abominable et
ignoble si on a une consommation
raisonnée on aura un maître une mode de
production et un mode d'abattage qui
sera raisonnée lui aussi voilà donc il
est là l214 là ils ont fait un travail
formidable en revanche là où je suis pas
d'accord c'est qu'elle 214 c'est le nom
que porte une association qui est vegan
c'est à dire qui est pour l'interdiction
totale le taux de consommation de viande
de protéines animales et là je dis non
la planète est ainsi fait il ya un
équilibre biologique l'être humain pour
moi il est omnivore ont pour le débat
l'être humain il ya un aspect 6 où il ya
un artiste pessisme ils sont ils disent
voilà c'est pas vrai les êtres humains
et les animaux sont appelant soit à mes
plans même plan tuer un animal c'est
humain congénères non non il ya des
races animales qu'ont été créés par
l'homme dans le cadre d'une production
agricole pour être consommés maintenant
il faut les élever de sas ondine
respectueuse qui parce qu'en plus ils
ont aussi bénéficié d'un élevage de
qualité dans une nature respecter la
qualité alimentaire devrait être
meilleure et surtout ils seront abattus
dans des conditions acceptables et
descentes mais la consommation de viande
est et rentrent à l'être humain nous
sommes des êtres humains aujourd'hui
développer si nous pouvons débattre de
ça et si l 214 peut mener ce combat
c'est parce que nos ancêtres ont
consommé de la viande c'est à dire qu'il
ya une consommation de protéines qui à
développer l'intelligence humaine qui a
développé la société la sociologie
humaine on peut aujourd'hui s'en passer
on peut manger que des protéines
d'origine végétale je dis pas le
contraire et génère moi je me battrai
pour que les jeunes puissent exiger
j'ouvre une parenthèse qui à développer
l'intelligence de l'homme c'est le fait
de cuire ses aliments ce qui permettait
à utiliser moins d'énergie pour la
digestion alors le singe se redresse
parce qu'il a besoin de cueillir des
attentions est sorti le canoë-kayak ray
le singe donc le cerveau grandi et là il
dit aux prédateurs
le drame c'est que l'être humain l'homme
est un loup pour l'homme c'est le
notaire est c'est ce côté prédateur
voilà prédateurs parce qu'à un moment
donné il faut comme il se développe il a
besoin de plus de protéines son statut
d'animal simiesque ils eux qui se
contentent de végétal et de fruits au
départ on va dire qu'avant qu'il soit
totalement hominidés l'homme et
fructidor l'humanoïde effectivement un
moment donné la consommation protéines
carnet devient essentiel à son
développement et à son essor et là il
devient un chasseur l'aï dit un
connaisseur c'est ça qui fait l'humanité
quel talent et je dis pas que c'est bien
c'est comme ça moi en tout cas je ne
renoncerai pas ou vendues pour des
raisons alimentaires pour des raisons
éthiques pour des raisons de bioéthique
je ne considère je ne renoncerai pas à
une consommation raisonnée de viande
respectueuse de la souffrance animale de
l'environnement et de la rétribution
l'éleveur bon bah non à des prédateurs
dans les supermarchés
votre avis de tuer un veau par exemple
c'est l'âge d'un enfant lui a pas fait
il a plu toute l'expérience doute
planait dans les champs de voir tout ça
c'est hypothétique c'est une question
qui vient d'internet
c'est la tiens c'est là c'est le fait de
tuer l'animal jeunes c'est vrai pour
l'agneau c'est vrai pour le poulet c'est
vrai pour le veau ils font partie de
notre culture alimentaire toutes les
manières si c'était dans la nature il ya
des prédateurs qui le tuerai tous les
jours partout sur la planète il ya des
millions d'animaux qui sont tués les
intérieurs là ce qu'on nous dise si oui
mais c'est à l'état de naturel et
sauvage c'est normal qu'un tigre mange
un agneau c'est normal qu'un lion mange
une bb gazelle
nous on peut pas parce qu'on est doté
d'une conscience mais le choix ou sinon
on a chois d'abord je m'interdis pas de
se priver de viande je dis que dans
cette culture alimentaire le sacrifice
de l'animal à tous les âges fait partie
de notre système alimentaire voilà alors
effectivement un moment donné le petit
veau et je les vois souvent et je pense
chaque fois que j'en vois pas ce que
j'en vois dans les champs je vais
beaucoup dans les campagnes je vais dans
des fermes dans les élevages je vois des
petits des petits avions et vous vous
frottez du monde iront ce bon petit saut
dites vous non non parce que oui oui
pourquoi je me dis cet animal n'a été
levée pour ça il va être sacrifiée et je
veux rendre hommage à saluer le fait que
cet animal va être sacrifiée pour me
nourrir pour m'alimenter que je vais en
plus autour de cette table où il va être
préparé je vais l'honorer story puisque
je vais d'ici là la vie c'est ça quelque
part quelque part mais si demain on me
dit voilà il faut plus manger du tout
vaut plus du tout d'agneau je vivrai
quand même très bien alors je vais venir
là faut plus manger que les vieux faut
pas manger les jeunes je trouve que les
jeunes et les vieux ont pas être je veux
pas de racisme de génération ou ont tué
un animal d'élevage parce qu'il a été
levée pour être consommés par l'homme de
façon décente je redis ou alors on en
mange plus du tout voilà je vois pas
pourquoi j'ai pas nuire et un veau une
petite un petit agneau ou un poulet et
pourquoi je tuerai sa mère son père ou
son oncle quand même temps celle d'une
vache ça peut vivre 18 20 en
place oui et plus elle est plus elle est
vieille plus elle a fait de vos plus
elle a fait d'eux les plus sa chair est
bonne si elle a été élevée à l'herbe
voilà et aujourd'hui le drame s'est
concerté qui juge les matchs maintenant
à bas à partir de 2-3 ans quelquefois
des génisses compas fait de beauval à
elles sont dès lors elles sont vraiment
destinés à la boucherie terres qu'elles
naissent pour mourir autrefois la viande
tels que la consommer
les anciens les sociétés la vache elle
elle faisait son veau elle faisait du
lait avec lequel on story c'est 11 et du
fromage faisait des veaux et pee ou 3 4
5 6 7e au bon balle et et harry parce
qu'elle est belle pour lui donner les
dons qu'elle était plus bonnes affaires
les veaux plus bonne affaire du leap au
frère de fromage on la remet tait dans
la campagne à l'herbe on l'a nourricier
donc de vote elle refaisait un peu de
gras et là on la battait elle avait une
carrière complète c'était sa carrière sa
carrière de vache bon sur lcp de tête
vous avez dit manon la mauvaise bouffe
donne des gens groulx et il est riche
maman mange sainement ils sont ils sont
tous faim bon vous êtes riche vous est
posée le paradoxe moi je suis considéré
socialement dans les gens riches voilà
j'ai des revenus qui sont certainement
par le mythique jeu fait qu'ils sont à
la moyenne alors je suis toujours plus
prouve que certains et plus riches que
d'autres ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'autrefois les pauvres étaient maigres
pour les voiliers famélique et
aujourd'hui la malbouffe à le paradoxe
de engendré l'obésité c'est parce que
justement on leur fait bouffer en
quantité immense tout et n'importe quoi
de façon abominable que justement les
classes défavorisées à qui on a permis
d'accéder à cette malbouffe qui est pas
cher à une algue aussi les apesi parce
que vous avez un quart d un petit peu ce
qu'ils avaient dans la malle douce et ça
c'est aussi un an d impression de sucre
la bonne vieille formule latine des
romains panem et circences s donnait
l'heure du pain des cirques donc
aujourd'hui on leur donne des émissions
de télé de grande diffusion
mutualité cuit - d'issoudun ne suscite
pas non mais enfin on s'est posé à quoi
je prends pas de nom mais voyez c'est
qu'on ait foi scaphandre poursuivre la
conversation tellement c'est nul imed ça
et ensuite ils vont en grande surface
chercher du suc et de la grèce pas cher
il s'en gavent donc ils sont obèses
malade et puis pendant ce temps là il
pense pas ils regardent la télé ce qui
fait que le stade d'après on leur dit
ben faut voter comme ça comme vous voyez
c'est la phrase de patrick le lay qui
est constitutif de notre civilisation
quart d'heure de cerveau disponible
voilà mon métier c'est de vendre c'est
de mettre à disposition d'une avait cité
une marque de soda américain cette même
du temps de cerveau humain disponible
pour que au delà de mes séries
américaines un peu émolliente du cortex
spot de pub puisse rentrer directement
comme dans du beurre ce qui fait qu
ensuite quand il arrive dans le
rayonnage hop il voit tout de suite la
marque il ya même des sociétés comme vu
à la télé sur le paquet c'est même pas
la peine de lire la marque a marqué vu à
la télé c'est formidable donc vous
ingurgitez ça une fois vous êtes gave et
vous repartez tout de suite devant
l'écran qui va vous redonner des
consignes publicitaire commerciale que
vous allez observer immédiatement à la
grande surface aujourd'hui
85% des français des consommateurs
français achètent les 14 repas de la
semaine cette fois de 14 entre 15 et 18
heures le samedi il met ça dans un
chariot et on achète moins cher ensuite
ça coûte très cher s'est pressée ménage
repassage ménage repassage et puis un
petit coup de son site planant peppuy
faiblit pas pour citer de noms des
missions vous voyez bien bien au raz des
pâquerettes voilà et on vit comme ça et
tout le monde est content après tout bon
quelque part on peut presque vivre avec
avec le smic je me dis que le système
que certains hommes politiques nous ont
proposé
quasiment on n'a plus besoin de
travailler si on va vous donner un fixe
par mois et dans se fixe on aura fait en
sorte qu'on puisse tellement obtenir de
merde à pas cher à tous les niveaux un
vestimentaire les loisirs la bouffe on
va vous donner un forfait 1500 à 2000
euros vous aurez rien besoin de faire
c'est sur votre compte en banque ça sera
directement prélevée par les organismes
commerciaux qu'ils auront dit qu'ils y
mettront à la vente et puis de votre
naissance jusqu'à votre mort on aura
tous programmés comment vous allez vous
habiller ou es ce que vous avez en
vacances ou es ce que vous avez habité
donc quoi vous allez roulez et que ce
que vous allez bouffer seul et ça sera
parfait expo l'union soviétique ce
alors c'était c'est une forme de
collectivisation sauf que là c'est du
communisme reconstitué sur une base
privatiser parce que le pognon de ce
profit il va pas à l'état il va pas
l'actualité vite et il va à des sociétés
à des multinationales néolibérale qui
sont entrain de [__] la planète pour
nous pour vous transformer en moutons
qui font de l'évasion fiscale et en plus
évidemment ils n'ont pas envie de payer
trop d'argent à la collectivité parce
que cette malbouffe été les principales
bénéficiaires quand la malbouffe devient
un fléau de santé en france où la santé
remboursées par les fonds publics c'est
l'industrie pharmaceutique qu'est ce que
dit le bi pharmaceutique au lobby
agroalimentaire de la malbouffe et à la
grande distribution
mon la pratique continue comme ça je
m'en fout plein les fouilles tu m'as
jamais fait vendre autant de médicaments
ne me dis pas ça vous imaginez bien le
dialogue c'est ne dit ne toucher à rien
continuez comme ça ne changeait rien
plus il ya de mal bouffe puis joindre
médicaments puisque puis à djamal a trop
besoin de se soigner plus à des
ordonnances et en france est formidable
puisque c'est là que la collectivité qui
paye la santé qui rembourse la maladie
il ya des pays où c'est pas remboursé
ton diabète ton cancer de maladies
cardiovasculaires tu t'appelles en
france et pris en charge par la
collectivité nationale je me faire
l'avocat du diable et les fonds publics
c'est peut-être aussi les laboratoires
qui cherche aussi à soulever les gens de
leur âge leur addition alimentaire c'est
tout le paradoxe c'est loin aussi dans
son serment d'hippocrate il ya beaucoup
de médecins qui ont qui ont participé à
des crimes contre l'humanité qu'ils
avaient ils avaient fait le serment
d'hippocrate donc quand vous faites
quelque chose le nucléaire c'est pour
faire se peut faire des choses
totalement pacifique on fait aussi des
bombes atomiques donc il ya des sciences
aujourd'hui c'est la phrase de rabelais
science sans conscience n'est que ruine
de l'âme aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
scientifiques qui n'ont pas de
conscience et qui se rend trois d'uriné
l'âme humaine je voue une parenthèse un
kubrick qui sur notre chat ne donne pas
de nous inviter il fait 14 degrés ça va
on se nourrit de l'échangeur il faut les
mettre un peu il faut les mettre un peu
sous pression et revenir revenons
comportement alimentaire ça va être les
fait l'un le foie gras la souffrance
animale
l214 c'est un peu investi sur le sujet
j'ai eu l'impression qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec avec c'est une cirrhose de
forlan alors on va examiner les
consignes qui nous sont données qui vont
commencer avant de bombarder on va nous
envoyer dans des grandes surfaces
achetez du saumon fumé dégueulasse de
saumon elle fait élevés dans des fermes
concentrés dans les fermes aquacoles de
norvège élevés dans des conditions
abominables cissé cité le nom d'église
pourquoi ce second parce que
gustativement les gens trouvent que
c'est bon on leur a dit que c'était bien
que c'était pas cher que c'était du
saumon fumé ils ont l'impression qu'ils
mangent du saumon fumé comme ceux qui
mangent du vrai saumon fumé et puis on a
baissé les prix donc on a fait en sorte
que ce produit soit vraiment infâme et
on va distribuer de façon industrielle
au mas qui vont se jeter dessus et quand
ils auront fini leur tranche de saumon
fumé dégueulasse sous plastique élevés
dans des commissions minable maintenant
faudra attaquer le foie gras est aussi à
des grandes sociétés qui font du foie
gras industriels provenant d'élevage de
canards élevés des conditions
abominables et on va acheter un produit
que sur lesquels il ya le mot foie gras
qui est pas du tout un frère arkin kinsa
le prix poursuit-il ça prend un morceau
de volailles élevées dans les mêmes
conditions et on aura dit par les
médecins conseils du jeu et des cirques
mais voilà votre réveillon et vous a
coûté x pas cher bon vous vous êtes un
peu un peu foutu la santé en l'air au
passage les gens qui ont produit ces
aliments ont abîmé la planète ont abîmé
l'environnement eux mêmes d'ailleurs on
n'a pas tiré profit et puis les vrais
producteurs les vrais éleveurs les vrais
paysans ils sont en train de crever
alors que les produits qui nous aurait
proposé si on veut bien manger un petit
peu moins eh bien ces gens-là vivre et
mieux et nous aussi autrement dit quelle
est ma consigne au lieu d'acheter six
tranches de saumon fumé dégueulasse et
300 g de foie gras immonde industriel
provoqué produits dans les conditions
affamés qui provoque des maladies
réduisez de moitié ou de deux tiers
cette quantité si vous voulez rester sur
le foie gras et le saumon fumé réduisez
la quantité mais offrez vous un vrai
saumon fumé et un vrai foie gras vous en
mangerez moins vous en mangerez mieux
vous allez faire du bien à tout le monde
à toute la filière et surtout à vous
même c'est un choix de société c'est le
moins et mieux 10 8 6 3 il ya toujours
une possibilité de s'en sortir avec le
même budget à la fin des fêtes les gens
à qui je m'adresse ils n'auront pas
dépenser un centime de plus je vais vous
dire ils ont regagné de l'argent parce
qu'ils seront bien portants ils auront
peut-être enrichit la bonne économie de
leur pays il ya toujours une solution
une question d'internet concernant la
surproductivité
les avenues firme dû sécher a trouvé
mort pendant sa peau les firmes ou
millevaches mais cet élevage intense il
y avait les élevages un trafic la
question c'est peut-on parler de crimes
contre l'humanité et contre la nature
l'élevage intensif
7 et crimes contre l'animalité puisque
je rappelle que moi qui suis
consommateur de viande je n'accepte de
consommer de la viande entre intensifs
un ultra intensifs voilà il ya une
éthique de production et je n'accepte
que de manger de la viande et merci l214
de m'avoir éveillé qui vient d'un
système de production respectueux et de
l'animal de l'environnement la
souffrance animale
lorsqu'on est dans un système de
concentration le mot concentration et
veut dire ce qu'il est on concentre pour
produire plus vite mieux en plus grande
quantité et faire plus de profit et la
l'animal dans ces cas là c'est plus un
animal c'est un c'est un élément c'est
une matière première si du minerai s'est
dit minerai est d'ailleurs le terminal
existe puisque et on l'a su grâce au
scandale des lasagnes avec de la viande
de cheval qui était qu'à remplacer la
viande de boeuf c'était du minerai quand
on sait comment il me les films minerais
tels comprend l'animal dans sa totalité
tout ça est broyé dans des conditions
atroces et on a un espèce de pain de
viande dégueulasse et c'est avec ça
qu'on va faire des plats cuisinés donc
effectivement
l'industrialisation de nos campagnes on
a transformé le paysan le terme il a en
ouvriers agricoles et nos campagnes en
usine et ben on aboutit à ces
aberrations taire tout le monde est
malheureux la nature est abîmée
l'environnement est pourri et la
condition animale elle devient ignoble
et en plus comme il faut faire vite et
pas cher on abat ses animaux dans des
conditions atroces donc effectivement la
ferme des millevaches c'est le symbole
de ce qu'il faut pas faire c'est une
erreur alors c'est c'est trente quarante
mille vaches aux états unis ces
vingt-cinq mille cochons en allemagne où
60 mille cochons voilà on transforme un
élément naturel qui est là pour nourrir
l'humanité en usine à profit pour
dégager du pognon et du fric eh bien ça
ça conduit l'humanité à sa perte et la
planète au cas où vous avez déjà eu des
problèmes que différents lobbys ou pas
du tout
tel que je m'exprime non ils m'aiment
pas il me souhaite tout le mal qu'ils
peuvent mais on est en france je suis
encore je suis encore en vie je pense
que il ya certains thèmes qu'on à
broadway dans d'autres pays où il ya
moins de droits de l'homme et moins de
démocratie j'aurais peut-être plus de
plus de problèmes et j'ai eu une fois ou
deux peut-être voilà une confrontation
judiciaire il ya des fois où je gagne il
ya des fois où je perds mais voilà j'ai
pas eu de grands conflits parce que ce
que je dis je ne diffame pas je les
traite pas de [__] je les traite pas
de pourri je dis que le système est
pourri bon mais c'est des gens qui
mènent un système économique auquel ils
croient aujourd'hui bon bah on voit bien
la finalisation de l'alimentation c'est
factuel il est mise en place par des
institutions comme la commission
européenne qui nous dit faut protéger
l'environnement faut améliorer la santé
des gens et la qualité alimentaire et on
signe le ceta en attendant s'il ne
doivent pas évidemment qui sont la
négation et l'annulation de toutes ces
mesures c'est une classe politique qui
nous dit je vais vous soigner et en même
temps elle signe un papier par lequel va
aggraver la situation voilà donc le
problème il est là le biou est-ce que
l'on peut nourrir tout le monde rubio
s'est pas est-ce qu'on peut c'est quand
est ce qu'on va vite faire en sorte de
pouvoir donné à tout le monde en bio
alors le mot bio je reconnais qu'il a
peut être une connotation aujourd'hui
idéologique et politique je m'en fous le
mot bio c'est une alimentation qui
respecte l'environnement la nature et
qu'ils fassent pas de mal à ça celui qui
le consomment donc aujourd'hui à 5 6 7
milliards d'habitants on voit les
problèmes que ça pose sur le plan
environnemental et climatique puisque
ces grandes puissances day faire les
coqs 21 22 23 24 combien aucune
contrainte on sait très bien que ça ne
sert à rien ça n'aboutit à rien tu es
présent la république a dit l'autre jour
si on fait pas ce qu'il faut on est en
train de tout perdre on est en train de
perdre une bataille merci de le
reconnaître au moins lui dit la vérité
parce que quand on a fait la coop 21 il
ya deux ans que c'était la grande fête
vous sonnez dans le nord de paris et on
disait m a dit il n'y a pas de clause
qui soit qui garantissent que ça se
passe mais toujours l'oiseau de mauvais
augure à vous est aigri tout le monde
reconnaît aujourd'hui que c'est un coup
d'épée dans l'eau eh bien
quand tant qu'on n'aura pas des vraies
contraintes pour obliger le système à
s'autoréguler et à respecter
l'environnement eh bien eh bien on aura
rien donc moi j'attends des institutions
qu'elle prenne des mesures efficaces en
fonction d'intérêts des citoyens et
qu'on mette les gens qui nous font du
mal face à leurs responsabilités
alors une question d'internet manger
c'est voter véhicule son émission sur
public sénat est sponsorisé par la
fondation beastly
voilà je suis très content qu'on aborde
cette question je suis dans internet oui
et je suis dans la commande dans la
jurisprudence ni kullas nicolas hulot
qui visait son émission ushuaïa
financier par tf1 qui est pas forcément
un organisme qui est écologique moi si
elle organise tel tels que nestlé qui
est au coeur du problème qui est
confronté à cette réalité la malbouffe
le pdg de nestlé il se bat contre la
grande distribution en disant c'est vrai
c'est moi qui produit cette alimentation
qui est contesté et qui peut être
contestable quelques fois mais pourquoi
est-ce que je suis obligé de produire
quelque chose qui est assimilée
malbouffe parce que le prix à laquelle
la grande distribution sans laquelle je
ne peux pas décelé me produis m'impose
une des tarifs qui maquille qui va
obliger à faire cette qualité là si on
acceptait de payer un petit peu plus je
pourrais faire quelque chose de mieux
quand cet organiste appelle les sleecs à
une fondation le l'esprit la fondation
les bases de la fondation c'est
justement d'inverser cette tendance et
bien si elle vient me voir et qu'elle me
dit je veux bien vous accompagner dans
cette émission par lequel moi je peux
faire passer des messages fondamentaux
pour le citoyen consommateur si grâce à
cette émission que personne d'autre me
permet de financer si c'est la fondation
nestlé qui me permet de financer ça et
bien merci la fondation leslie point
final moi je l'assumé totalement est
complètement dépendant je suis
totalement dépendant il ya aucune
contrainte et si un jour nestlé me dit
bon là pericos ce que vous dites
ne me va pas eh bien j arrêterai
d'ailleurs j'annonce tout simplement que
le sponsoring de la fondation destinée
de cette année j'en cherche un autre
parce que j'ai envie de changer j'ai pas
envie de me marier avec eux mais je dire
merci de m'avoir accompagné
solennellement pendant ces trois années
de manger c'est voter où ils ont été là
et sans eux je n'aurais pas pu faire
cette émission qui pour moi manger c'est
voter et fondatrice du discours que je
veux transmettre aux citoyens
consommateurs un avis sur l'avion du
heavy trou
d'ignobles alors là je deviens
végétarien tout de suite et je les dis
si c'est si la seule viande comment
proposer c'est ça je deviens vegan tout
de suite et gestes et sans hésitation et
sans nom pour moi ce qui me plaît et je
reviens petit peu à l'histoire du veau
ce qui me plaît dans cette consommation
de viande c'est que tu manges un animal
qu'est né dans la nature qui est né de
façon naturelle il a été levé dans un
paysage il a mangé de l'herbe je dis
toujours un petit peu hypocritement moi
je suis plus végétalien que les autres
parce que ma côte de boeuf et mon
fromage c'est de l'herbe intelligemment
transformé par la vache ou par la brebis
qui s'est transformé en muscles ou ou en
fromage mais au départ c'est de l'herbe
donc moi ce qui me porte culturellement
dans la consommation de viande c'est que
cet animal est le reflet d'un paysage
d'une nature dans l'environnement et moi
je savoure parce que je suis je suis
gastronome seigneur je donne une
dimension culturelle fait d'un immersion
de plaisir évidemment que cette viande a
un goût spécial parce que l'éleveur a
fait en sorte que cette volaille seveau
7,7 agneaux ont été élevés dans ce dans
les conditions naturelles qui fait qu'il
ya une qualité de viande est une qualité
alimentaire ya une qualité gustative et
je vais la réduire au maximum parce que
j'ai pas envie que justement qu'on tombe
dans le d'intensifs mais je la garderais
si on me dira maison il ya un moment
l'esclavagé c'était quand même
culturelle les scratchs et et culturels
on s'en émanciper et finalement est ce
que quelque part est ce que quelque part
il a vraiment été abolie par rapport aux
écarts parce que quelqu'un qu'on paye
200 300 250 euros pour un travail de
dans sa voiture voilà je voudrais savoir
ou est le seuil de l'esclavagé quelque
part c'est le problème de la guerre de
sécession le sud était jusque là
magistrat corps est ce que vraiment la
société nord américaine qui en a découlé
a été vraiment une révolution pour les
noirs je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
vraiment été je pense qu'il a fallu
attendre plus longtemps pour que les
choses soient vraiment remise en ordre
question d'internet votre vous vous le
manger de façon naturelle mais ça a été
un simili
parce que c'est pas un viol de la vache
alors là c'est mon boulot de m'assurer
que l'origine de l'animal les conditions
d'élevage la façon dont il a évidente il
est né est le plus naturel possible donc
effectivement si ma viande elle sort
d'une usine qui s'appelle une étape qui
est devenue une usine où on a poussé les
animaux aujourd'hui
90 % de la viande qu'on trouve dans le
commerce français dans la grande
distribution c'est de la viande poussé à
la va vite de façon industrielle et
souvent nourries avec du tourteau de
soja ogm importé du brésil ou
d'argentine moi je lis consommateurs 7
vient de là j'en veux pas donc je
préfère réduire de moitié de deux tiers
la consommation de viande et m'assurer
que je mange une viande qui vient d'un
élevage français parce que je suis
français mais y en a très beau en italie
en espagne on veut une vache une brebis
un agneau à cochons élevés dans une
nature respectée dans un environnement
propre et qui a été élevé de façon
respectueuse et cap a été inséminée com
com comment on fait des mouvements une
machine mais qui a été fait de façon
naturelle parce que la seule valeur
ajoutée que peut avoir cet animal c'est
d'avoir été élevé d'avoir été nourris
dans des conditions naturelles le moment
où j'apprends que ça a été fait d'une
façon inacceptable et maman plaisir de
déguster de la viande ma démarche
culturelle humain de déguster des
produits carnés c'est un et là je passe
aux légumes immédiatement la condition
que le légume et été aussi élevées parce
que vous avez la même chose en légumes
l'industrie lisant les campagnes c'est
pas seulement l'élevage intensif vous
avez aussi de la production intensif et
il faut dire la vérité aujourd'hui les
grandes maladies elles sont surtout dues
aux pesticides aux fongicides enfin
toutes les saloperies chimiques que l'on
met dans la culture végétal beaucoup
plus que dans la culture animal c'est
beaucoup plus par le légumes et de
fruits contaminés qu'on s'empoisonne que
par le mystère qu'est ce que vous pensez
des nouvelles pratiques de manger des
insectes mangent et d
déjà signé des choses comme ça avoir une
source de protéines
moi je sais que je peux remplacer
si vraiment je décide de ne plus
consommer de protéines carnet d'origine
animale je vais me rabattre sur une et
une alimentation équilibrée protéines ou
pas mais j'étale mois l'insecte
ça me dit rien andré gauthier oui j'ai
déjà goûté ça n'a aucun intérêt c'est
aussi un écrivain mais parce que dans la
culture alimentaire de sanaa mais je
respecte totalement des populations des
sociétés vous avez voyagé un petit peu
j'ai voyagé bon mais c'est pas là haut
mais j'ai goûté mois surtout en france
des années parce qu'aujourd'hui à des
sociétés qui met ça en place je vois pas
du tout l'intérêt
vraiment manger manger des chenilles
croustillantes alors c'est vrai qu'on va
venir ça ressemble à la petite crevette
qu'on décortique ouais moi je préfère
quand même là crevettes fraîches qui
vient de la mer que je mange comme ça
que de manger un à cinq quand on voit là
pour moi cela culturellement aucun
intérêt nutritionnel mans 0 et sur le
plan alimentaire j'en ai pas envie mais
je respecte les gens qui viennent là et
si on m'explique que de consommer des
insectes dont on a quand même tué mais
on me dit oui même système nerveux on va
quand même sacrifier un animal un petit
insecte après tout pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils seraient moins - moins
respectable qu'une qu'une vache aucune
au canadien si on me dit
cette consommation de protéines origines
insectes va permettre de consommer moins
de viande industrielle ben ce moment là
je soutiendrai cette initiative les
faubourgs et si je vous dis que on a un
ami qui a été voir le vatican pour dire
voilà ça fait 2000 au vous êtes les
meilleurs en propagande pour influencer
vos fidèles il faudrait leur faire
passer le message qu'il faudrait
vraiment vraiment se calmer sur la
consommation de viande
pour des questions soutenabilité
sociétale est ce que vous seriez prêt à
refaire cette demande auprès du vatican
mais évidemment le christ dans sa colère
au temple vous vous croyez vous à vous
avez un ami imaginons pas
je vais vous dire j'ai pas le temps
j'essaie d'avoir un comportement sur
terre je suis dans le pari de pascal
j'ai pas la réponse à l'origine de
l'univers et à ce que nous faisons sur
cette planète en tant qu' en tant
qu'être humain je vais essayer de me
comporter de façon le plus correct je
vais essayer d'être sympa jeu pour mon
passage sur terre je me conforme et un
texte qui est pas trop mal qui s'appelle
les évangiles qui est assez à gauche
finalement quand on l'appliqué devrait
et le drame de l'église c'est que jésus
était un un militant de gauche c'est un
vrai socialiste et que saint paul qui
était le représentant du système à faire
en sorte que l'église catholique de
vienne ce qu'elle est mais au départ le
christianisme originel tel qu'il est
conçu dans les premières évangiles
c'est le vrai sens du partage d'aller
vers l'autre c'est la générosité et
l'amour partagé donc je vais essayer de
me rapprocher à peu près de ses
consignes la d'évangile sigean respecte
10 15 12% ça sera énorme et puis s'il ya
un grand arbitre la faim qui à la sortie
du film me regarde et qui me dit tu
croyais pas j'ai trop de monde ouais
t'as mangé tu reviens tu croyaient pas
en moi mais ton comportement est
acceptable alors que l'autre allait à la
messe tous les dimanches et qui
remplissait tous les codes de l'église
c'est un [__] voilà bah oui ben je
préfère être passé croyant pas avoir la
foi est un comportement super assez
correct vis-à-vis de mes congénères que
d'être un dévot respectueux de toutes
les consignes et idéologiques et
religieuses qui assure cette terre parce
qu'un gars qui sont des veaux et qui se
comportent comme des [__] ouais ça
déconne sur le chat à fond ils sont en
train de lancer des vannes à gogo bon
passons je les prends à l'éval way est
rancunier week-end c'est vous la prenez
aussi
et c'est très bien jaj on allait plaisir
qu'on veut exactement quand on vous
avait déjà mis un animal à son chou à
mort est ce que vous êtes chasseur est
ce que vous avez déjà pratiqué la lie
alors je ne suis pas chasseur mais
j'appartiens à une famille il ya eu des
chasseurs et quand j'étais gamin c'était
un bonheur que faire le parcours de
chasse j'allais dire dans une dimension
écologique faut pas être faux culs mais
je vais me promener et j'ai aimé voir
7,7 ce circuit dans la nature et un coup
d'oeil dans une mine au moins ça ça m'a
ça m'a toujours et j'étais plutôt du
genre comme si si dans le film avec son
papa j'étais plutôt dangereux a poussé
le fusil on doit tous et pour que
l'animal s'en aille parce que je suis
quand même toujours du côté de que de
celui qu'on poursuit donc il y avait une
ambiguïté mais voir un animal comme ça
sauve a jeté sur sa branche en oiseau ou
un sanglier ou un daim ou 1 ou 1 ou un
chevreuil qui se baladent et con tu vois
là et j'ai déjà mis chasseurs je suis
toujours un peu dans le conflit avec eux
j'ai des amis qui aiment la corrida ça
suffit toujours pas des engueulades
épouvantable parce que pour moi c'est
quand même une ce pacte militaire même
si la chasse est un acte allez c'est une
tradition occidentale très française
c'est vrai que des chasseurs qui sont
des protecteurs de la nature parce qu'il
faut réguler guéret chaussures qui font
grimper la nature c'est tout à fait ils
sont de moins en moins nombreux là je
connais beaucoup de chasseurs qui laisse
tomber parce que ça devient un sac voilà
mais c'est vrai que de tuer l'animal
comme ça qui est beau et sur sa branche
ou dans son champ c'est quand même
violent même si je me retiens aussi
c'est culturel non je sais bien et je
suis très faux cul parce que je me
régale avec un bon perdreaux de beauce
et quand il ya une gigue de chevreuil
qui est préparée dans les règles de
l'art c'est aussi la corrida c'est
culturel alors la corrida c'est une
c'est totalement culturel je respecte
les gens qui considèrent ces culturel et
qui y vont n'empêche que je ne suis pas
choqué qu'on l'interdise
c'est un rituel qui vient de la nuit des
temps probablement de la grèce antique
de la civilisation minoenne les
espagnols en ont fait un acte de
barbarie légal et accepté un contrat
d'un an
pour moi c'est quand même le fait de
torture et l'animal il serait abattu
tout de suite comme ça c'est pas une
excuse mais voilà de voir cette scène de
torture progressive
dans cet animal qui étaient là qui
défend sa vie le taureau c'est un animal
formidable c'est un animal noble le
taureau la lettre à les anciens
orientaux le savez bien les phéniciens
là les trains c'est là c'est les cornes
inversée donc c'est vraiment la base de
la culture humaine le symbole du taureau
les cornes vers le ciel voilà et ont
fait recette cet instrument de
souffrance et de torture avec des gens
qui applaudissent c'est c'est la
reconstitution ou la permanence des jeux
du cirque romain qui était quand même le
symptôme même si c'était une situation
très évolué c'était quand même le reste
d'un corps un comportement barbare donc
je respecte les gens qui me disent je
vais à la corrida mais quand un
gouvernement prend la décision de
l'interdire je trouve qu'il va dans le
bon sens est-ce que vous avez des
conseils pour trouver les bonnes
filières pour bien se tenir
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de gens sur
terre et en france qui se donne du mal
paysans des agriculteurs des artisans
pour faire en sorte que de plus en plus
de gens puissent accéder à des prix
acceptables à la bonne bouffe mais ça
impose toujours une démarche pas un
sacrifice mais une démarche faut prendre
le temps d'aller chercher ce produit il
faut prendre le temps de le préparer
mais l'acte culinaire est un acteur
social est un acte culturel est un acte
d'amour elle est achetée une barquette
de merde dans une grande surface et la
mettre dans le micro-ondes ingurgiter
voilà pour se débarrasser de cet acte
est contraignant est fastidieux qu'est
l'acte alimentaire donc on achète une
marque on bouffe une marque établie mais
aussi à la place de la mau mau qui
rentrent kyste récit par son taf qui a
pas le temps de cuisiner kaka ou tard
qu'ils sont énervés parce qu'ils ont
étaient surexcités sûr c'était pas le
sucre je la soupçonne et j'ai discuté
beaucoup avec des mères de familles
confrontés à cette réalité de temps je
la soupçonne beaucoup de me dire j'ai
pas le temps et quand je regarde bien
c'est sa vie privée elle est souvent
devant l'écran où je crois qu'on voit
beaucoup de conneries voilà alors il ya
des cas très précis de mères
célibataires trois enfants qui vivent
seuls dans une barre de banlieue elle
n'a pas le choix alors j'ai envie de lui
dire essayer de vous en sortir d'essayer
de faire différemment prenez un peu plus
on pourra les acheter de temps en temps
peut-être pas les quatre ans veut pas
aller au gameplay rossi peut faire les
et le sert aussi je disais qu'elle était
célibataire vraiment aller seuls dix
personnes battaient aussi à des pères
célibataires donc aux parents
célibataires essayez quand même de faire
un acte préparation de cuisine chez vous
parce que c'est un acte de civilisation
c'est un acte d'amour préparer le repas
quand on va poser le plat au milieu de
la table qui est pas forcément un truc
dégueulasse qu'on aura des conflits dans
un micro-ondes et qu'on aura préparé
avec amour en ayant accouché les
poireaux les patates en ayant battu
l'omelette et les enfants sont autour de
la table ils ont peut-être participer et
bien c'est un acte iv constitue je
considère qu'aujourd'hui la barbarie qui
s'empare de notre société vient de notre
comportement alimentaire le repas en
famille à la maison est constitutive de
la paix sociale il est constitutive du
tissu familial le fait d'avoir aboli
parce que l'industrie agroalimentaire à
la demande de la grande distribution a
fait du packaging individuel vous avez
aujourd'hui des foyers français il ya
six ou sept personnes chacun mange dans
son coin qui devant son écran qui devant
sa télé ils ont ce journal sa barquette
son truc voilà et donc le le tissu
social que constitue cet acte à gorik
quel repas autour natale et majorque une
société autrefois y avait plusieurs
générations qui a cohabité l'instant de
table et l instant de l' échange du
partage de la réflexion de la communion
est quelque part c'était l'instant on
sait mais autour d'une table parce que
si le plat est bon en plus âpre et
dispose à ce que les choses se passent
bien autour d'un bon pot-au-feu de
marque et de vaud ont fait pas la guerre
on fait plutôt l'amour on fait plutôt
l'amour à table en partageant quelque
chose de bon et bien cet acte est lisant
cacher leur tu fais la cuisine chez nous
c'est notre chien ou c ou alors c'est
moi qui fait qu'ils préparent à manger
je dis pas cuisiner parce que je reste a
aucun cuisinier que je connais moi je
prépare à manger je fais les courses je
prépare le repas et je m'occupe surtout
de repas des enfants la tâche a fait
trois ans par un gâteau mais elle a déjà
fait déjà beaucoup de choses elle fait
tout mieux que moi c'est la seule chose
où fut meilleur qu elle c'est pour ça
que je garde je regarde la primauté sur
la sur la cuisine on arrive dans le
temps où j'en à 20h35 et encore vous
avez tout ce que vous voulez bon art et
comme ces relations entre les filières
d'approvisionnement n'étaient sur cette
question là il faut terminer la wii
annonce les filières d'approvisionnement
m'ont fait pour mieux s'approvisionner
mais je reviens bien sûr
on sait dévié parce que j'étais parti
sur le repas mais la finalité de la
filière d'approvisionnement on va
aujourd'hui il ya suffisamment de deux
points de vente il ya suffisamment de
réseaux commerciaux de filières où on
nous propose des choses saines mais même
dans la grande distribution même si
c'est pas du bio à les acheter de la
nourriture fraîche et même dans
l'agriculture conventionnelle celles qui
utilisent encore un petit peu de
pesticides il ya eu des efforts
gigantesques en effet ya beaucoup moins
de produits chimiques avant il ya encore
des produits qui sont dégueulasses c'est
souvent les produits les moins chers
c'est ce que je dis aux gens qui tapent
dans leur budget alimentaire pour le
baisser au maximum pour garder des
moyens d'acheter autre chose attention
vous vous empoisonner s'est pas dit que
vous allez tomber malade c'est par dit
que vous avez en mourir la malbouffe
n'est pas une rafale de mitraillette qui
vous tuent dans la rue comme cela
instantanément mais on sait très bien
aujourd'hui on a suffisamment d'éléments
scientifiques pour savoir que la
malbouffe elle provoque des maladies qui
mettent du temps à se développer mais
quand elle se développe c'est trop tard
donc c'est important d'aller chercher
des aliments sains des aliments frais si
on a le courage et la conscience d'aller
chercher que des aliments bio même si
c'est une fois de temps en temps pouvoir
d'achat voire d'achat mais je vous ai
dit on réduit la quantité retenez dès 10
8 6 3 10 8 euros de budget au lieu de
faire 6 x 3 euros de berne je fais trois
trois fois 6 euros de bonne qualité je
vais chercher mes aliments parce que le
fait d'aller chercher chez le commerçant
ou même dans le rayon un légume une
viande qui ressemble à quelque chose un
poisson qui ressemble à quelque chose et
de le préparer à la maison c'est un acte
d'humanité on est en train de
transformer en barbare par notre mode de
consommation
la barbarisation du monde c'est un
consumérisme mercantile à échelle
industrielle qui est là pour donner du
fric à ceux qui veulent dégager des
profits et bien faire la révolution
aujourd'hui et mon livre c'est à ta le
citoyen on peut pas peser sur les grands
enjeux économiques on n'a pas de poids
sur wall street à titre individuel sur
les grands enjeux politiques même sur
les grands enjeux culturels et
médiatiques on n'a pas de prise
individuelle il ya un moment où nous
petits citoyens que nous sommes un autre
niveau dans la société on a trois
leviers par jour qu'on peut actionner au
petit déjeuner au déjeuner et au dîner
et là on peut faire ce qu'on veut on
peut acheter différemment on peut
consommer différemment on peut faire un
bras d'honneur à ces gens qui veulent
nous empoisonner prendre notre pognon
ils se comportaient de façon alimentaire
c'est ça qui va inverser le monde et je
dis que sur les calculs le nombre de
repas qui a en france 30 repas trop
tentants jour papa was de nous fait on
est soixante six millions d'habitants ça
fait 190 millions de repas par jour
d'actes alimentaire par jour en france
ça fait un sacré génocide la fameuse d
afrique 4 milliards est prévue de 4
milliards backed alimentaire par mois ça
fait 72 milliards d'actes alimentaires
par an sur le territoire de la
république française si 10 15 20 % de
ces actes alimentaire se passe de la
façon dont je le prescrit si on fait
attention à ce qu'on mange qu'on regarde
sous l'étiquette d'où ça vient qu'il a
fait est ce que ça fait du bien à
l'environnement est-ce que ça nourrit le
paysan qui l'a fait est ce que ça fait
sa femme sa bénéficie à une économique
et respectueuse de la nature et de la
terre eh bien on fait une révolution
bien plus violente que celle de
mélenchon bien plus violente que celle
de besancenot on répare les choses hélas
système ce n'est un sport gayraud avait
dit allez tout avant tout chercher notre
argent à la banque quand on va [__] le
système bancaire en l'air cesse-t-on bio
qui le dit c'est cantona merci cantona
j'ai pas très calé on vient vous je suis
un vrai tournant oui alors le pouvoir
puisse y était pour rien quand on peut
maintenant c'est cantona il avait si
tous les citoyens consommateurs disent à
partir d'aujourd'hui je fais attention à
ce que je mets dans l'assiette qu'est ce
que j'achète d'où ça vient comment c'est
fait je me comporte de façon responsable
en citoyen consommateur et je n'achète
pas n'importe quoi n'importe comment et
je refais à la maison de la cuisine avec
des produits frais il faut un bordel
sans nom dans ce système qu'il veut du
mal vous arrivez à la fin de notre
émission on est toujours un conseil pour
les jeunes générations on pose la
question à nous inviter de laisser cette
bouteille à la mer impérissable sur les
réseaux en plus c'est notre dernier
dernière vidéo de 2010 est donc à vous
de micro un conseil pour les jeunes et
conseils pour les jeunes eux ayez
conscience que on habite une planète
formidable je connais pas les autres
mais je sais qu'elle est belle je sais
que le destin de l'humanité sur terre
c'est de mettre en valeur cette maison
la maison perd cet environnement il nous
a été transmis par nos aînés de façon
respectueuse soyons respectueux de cette
planète est la meilleure façon de
respecter la planète c'est d'en vivre
de prendre ses ressources pour nos pour
s'en nourrir et de mettre en valeur ce
patrimoine donc c'est à table c'est dans
l'acte alimentaire et quand on est jeune
on aime les bonnes choses on aime les
douceurs on est gourmand on et gourmet
eh bien je dis à la jeunesse de france
en cette fin d'année 2010 est faites
vous plaisir en cette fin d'année
régalez vous achetez des choses
délicieuses mais assurez-vous douce et
vient qui l'a fait comment ça a été fait
vous rendrez service à votre pays vous
renversez miss à votre famille vous
rendre service à vous même et vous
saurez service à la planète et ça ça
message très important aujourd'hui et ce
à la portée de tout le monde merci
périco légasse est ce que pour 2018 vous
seriez chaud pour faire un petit débat
avec l 214 alors j'ai déjà débattu avec
les responsables de 114 qui sont pas des
amis me dit rien qui convergent et je
suis prêt bien entendu à reconnaître les
points d'accord que j'ai avec eux et
surtout exprimé pourquoi je suis pas je
suis en divergences avec certains de
leurs principes périco légasse merci
c'est moi qui vous remercie
[Musique]